[Music]
many fans cannot wait until they can
finally watch the upcoming venom let
there be carnage in theaters
we feel the same obviously and in order
to make the waiting time a bit easier
for you
we prepared an original episode for you
this week learn everything you need to
know about the new sony blockbuster
as well as the latest news in regards to
cast story and production
let's start with the storyline first
after the first film was released in
2018 fans were thrilled to bits and
notches due to the gripping and chaotic
story around eddie block aka venom
in particular one mid credit scene of
the film with tom hardy is significant
for part two
anyone who has seen venom will know
exactly what we mean we're talking about
the scene in which protagonist eddie
brock encounters serial killer cletus
cassidy aka carnage
in a maximum security prison cassidy
like brock is also the host of the
symbiote whose nature is at least as
terrifying as venoms in the mid-credit
scene cassidy who is played by woody
harrelson
announces that he is going to break out
of prison using the memorable words
let there be carnage at the latest from
this scene it was clear that a second
part was to come
not much is known about the plot but at
least you can get a rough idea from
venom let there be carnage based on some
leaked information
the first part ends spectacularly with
the explosion of the spaceship and the
death of eddie brock's nemesis dr carter
drake a.k.a right
as deadline also reported comic book
villain shriek will be assisting
antagonist carnage shriek whose real
name is
francis barrison is a drug dealer in the
comics who obtains her mutant powers due
to a
severe trauma her [ __ ] of superpowers
includes flying evoking traumatic
emotions in her opponent and the control
of
sound waves the latter should be
especially tough on venom
as he's known to be very sensitive to
frequency interference
another juicy detail from the comics is
that she is both carnage's accomplice
and his lover so her appearance is
considered to be
very likely despite the lack of
confirmation from sony's part
quite surprisingly a first almost two
minute trailer came out which gives a
first glimpse of the movie
eddie brock seems to have come to terms
with his dark side by now
and experiences some pretty funny upbeat
very absurd moments in everyday life
but not everything is as nice as it
seems at first glance as of course the
title
antagonist carnage also makes an
appearance in the first trailer
in one brutal scene for instance we can
witness cletus cassie transforming into
the terrified carnage
at the moment of his execution naomi
harris who will be playing the
aforementioned shriek in the upcoming
film is also featured all in all
an exciting first trailer that leaves
you wanting to see more
so now let's move on to the cast in
front of and behind the camera
the cast confirmed so far is of course
tom hardy is venom naomi here is a
shriek and woody harrelson has carnage
other confirmed cast members include
michelle williams's anne wieng and reed
scott as dr dan lewis
behind the scenes andy circus is
responsible for directing the
blockbuster
in 2019 brit took over the role from
ruben fleischer
as he was too busy producing zombieland
doubletap and lag time for venom 2.
the screenplay was originally written by
kelly marcel
but lead actor tom hardy was also very
much involved in the writing process
now let's take a look at the third
aspect the rumor mill surrounding venom
2
the rumor that spider-man will appear
more or less directly in the upcoming
sony film has been persistent for some
time
conveniently director andy circus has
analyzed the new trailer in a video from
ign
and revealed some bits of information
the 57 year old
acknowledges a certain connection
between spider-man and venom but at the
same time stresses that it was decided
to
isolate the venom universe from the
superhero therefore venom and carnage
do not know about peter parker's
existence still
that doesn't mean that clever fans won't
find a few easter eggs in this regard
venom let there be carnage does contain
some illusions
for example peter parker's employer the
daily bugle will also appear in the new
venom movie
since sony's new multiverse doesn't
really start until venom 2
we can most likely expect to see
spider-man in the upcoming blockbusters
surrounding morbius
craven the hunter the sinister 6 or
madame web
another connection to the mcu can also
be found in the new trailer
in one scene you can see an unfamiliar
man browsing through the daily bugle
if you slow down the video and pause at
the right moment you can see a headline
about the avengers on the right hand
side as seen from his perspective
sadly the text is only partially visible
and really cleverly hidden
but this is certainly not just a
coincidence the trailer also reveals an
interesting film location in the
beautiful panoramic view
the ravencroft institute to put it
crudely it's the arkham asylum of the
marvel universe and just like the dc
model
not all inmates leave the institute as
reformed criminals
specifically in vellum 2 ravencroft will
primarily act as the focus of various
scientific experiments most of which
will certainly revolve around
symbiotes and their hosts there are also
some indications that venom will set the
institute on fire during the course of
the film
you can tell it's going to be exciting
another easter egg revolves around none
other than spider-man
well at least a spider and the man in
the scene you can
see an unknown figure killing a spider
with his hand you don't have to be a pro
to recognize that is pretty much
carnage himself as can be seen by his
blue jumpsuit after all
obviously it's clear to everyone which
imagery this clip wants to convey and we
sincerely hope that this is a small
teaser of a big clash between cassidy
and peter parker
even though it's not going to happen in
this movie needless to say there are
many more easter eggs and clues to be
discovered so we'd be interested to hear
which ones you've spotted post them down
in the comments if you like
last but not least we want to introduce
you to the titular antagonist carnage
casually speaking carnage is the truly
evil one among spider-man's enemies
for while most of the adversaries have
experienced tragic events in their way
to become
villains and still possess some spark of
humanity it is simply a carnage's nature
to kill and destroy
before cletus cassidy was infected with
the symbiote carnage he was already a
criminal sadist this is certainly
one of the reasons why carnage is one of
the most difficult adversaries
simply because once he gets into fury
he's nearly unstoppable
if you will carnage is the nastier and
stronger version of venom as can be seen
quite well in this similarly designed
custom of the two the scope of the
superpowers is also impressive
as they include not only supernatural
strength agility and speed but also the
ability to block the popular superhero
spider-sense
moreover a currency symbiote grew on
earth rather than on the planet clina
which does make him more unstable and
unpredictable but also considerably
stronger than the main character venom
his greatest vulnerability is fire but
in exchange he is not as
acceptable to sonic weapons as his
counterpart all in all a very powerful
villain who will give protagonist eddie
brock some real trouble
that's it for our latest original
episode are you excited about venom let
there be carnage as we are and what are
your expectations of the new sony
blockbuster
let's chat in the comments if you also
enjoyed the video like and subscribe so
we can give you more insights into your
favorite movies in the future
see you next time
[Music]
you